bonsoir série heroes merci d'être avec
nous en direct usa france jean castex
qui a aussi lancé à nouveau un appel aux
soignants dernière appelle avant que la
vaccination devienne obligatoire pour
les soignants il est indispensable que
les soignants soient vaccinés pour
protéger leurs passions sont qui sont
fragiles alors il faut savoir que c'est
déjà le cas dans de nombreux endroits
selon les chiffres du bulletin de santé
publique france qui a été publiée au
mois de mai à 91% des soignants sont
vaccinés dans les hôpitaux
ça tombe à 63% dans les ehpad à mais il
faut savoir qu'il y a quand même qui
soucie de décalage technique dans le
temps à savoir que vous avez 125 dit le
soignant qui ont été contaminés par par
le cos vide 70 à l'hôpital 55000 dans
dans les étals et qu' il ya un délai de
plusieurs mois entre le moment où on est
infecté par aco vie et où le moment on a
une injection du vaccin ce qui explique
un peu ce décalage 63% ça n'explique
peut-être pas voilà ce entre guillemets
mauvais chiffre clairement thierry
amouroux pour vous rendre obligatoire
cette vaccination tout du moins pour les
soignants est ce que ce serait voilà la
solution équipement indispensable même
si elle peut être décriée dans notre
pays le fait de se vacciner c'est une
obligation morale déontologique pour
pour les soignants après le fait de le
rend obligatoire par la loi
ça peut avoir des effets
contre-productifs
d'abord on voyait un message à
l'ensemble de la population que les
soignants serait réticent la vaccination
encore une fois 91% des soignants à
l'hôpital sont vaccinés
et c'est là où il ya la majorité des
soignants sont pas dans les étals sont
dans les hôpitaux les chu c'était quand
même dans les ehpad
oui bien entendu c'est pour ça que je
vous dis qui est une obligation morale
et et anthologies après sur le jusqu'à
présent pour convaincre nos patients de
se vacciner on s'appuie justement sur le
fait que nous soignants nous sommes
soudés et on met en avant cette
exemplarité et les français
majoritairement et étaient sceptiques en
décembre dernier et puis aujourd'hui est
bien la grande majorité de la population
souhaitent se faire vacciner
et ça ça a été un travail de réaliser
sur le terrain en s'appuyant sur le
médecin de famille sur sur l'infirmière
habituel et donc c'est nous par le fait
que l'on soit vacciné on s'appuie
là-dessus on leur dit vous regardez moi
je me suis vacciné s
allez-y il faut le faire c'est important
voilà et si demain il ya cette
vaccination obligatoire on ne pourra
plus utiliser aussi facilement cet
argument parce que dès les gens prennent
pour nous dire bah oui mais vous êtes
axe idée mais c'est parce que c'est
obligatoire c'est pas de votre plein gré
donc ça envoie un message un peu bizarre
parce que encore une fois 91% la d'aidé
soignant à l'hôpital sont vaccinés
aujourd'hui terrain mauro 4 4 sont les
arguments qu'ils avancent ces soignants
pas quand ils ne sont pas pardon à
vacciner il ne le souhaite pas il se
méfier quel armement
faut bien comprendre que c'est une
minorité lorsqu'on regarde par exemple
en israël dans le plus grand hôpital de
jérusalem
vous aviez 80 agents réfractaires sur
sur 3000 vous avez la même situation en
italie ou en angleterre pour que c'est
ultra minoritaire
comprenez bien que l et les soignants
ont l'habitude de se vacciner parce
qu'ils y croient même et il ya déjà un
certain nombre de vaccins obligatoires
donc c'est dans notre adn
merci en tout cas thierry amouroux
d'avoir été notre invité ce soir en
direct sur rt france